falta poco para que las nuevas reglas
del pase sanitario entren en vigencia en
francia por cuarto fin de semana
consecutivo miles de franceses se dieron
cita en las calles de parís para
manifestar contra el certificado de
salud para muchos se trata de una ley
impuesta por el gobierno que no respeta
a la libre elección
soy padre de familia y quiero mantener
la libertad de proteger a mi hijo de la
vacuna
él no ha tenido de la enfermedad y
nuestra parte de los grupos de riesgo
del virus
hoy quiero mostrar una ilustración del
consentimiento libre e informado que
está en el código de salud pública el
consentimiento libre significa que no
hay chantaje que se ejerce sobre la
persona ni tampoco chantaje en el empleo
y tampoco para el acceso a ciertos
lugares y que no haya presión
psicológica ejercida sobre la persona
las manifestaciones se extendieron por
más de 150 ciudades de francia contra
este certificado de salud y también la
vacunación obligatoria para el personal
sanitario esta semana el consejo
constitucional francés aprobó las nuevas
disposiciones del pase y el documento
debe demostrar que la persona está al
día con la vacunación contra el coi 19 o
que tenga un resultado negativo para
poder ingresar a cafés restaurantes
centros comerciales entre otros lugares
que se suman al acceso ya restringido a
teatros cines discotecas y salas de
concierto más de 44 millones de
franceses ya han recibido al menos una
dosis de la vacuna contra el coronavirus
sin embargo el presidente manuel macro
no sigue llamando a las personas a
vacunarse